I am a Jew Verma I'm lawyer based in
Delhi and also full of international
business justice a not-for-profit
organization working to end torture by
providing early access to competent
counsel and throughout the world what I
fo z is is forum World Economic Forum
has given platform for social
entrepreneurs and the business leaders
to come together to irrigate the
problems what is being phased in
day-to-day life I also have a great hope
from the business leader that they will
partner with the authorities to
eradicate the problems faced especially
the area where I I am working in the
criminal justice system I hardly see any
industries collaborating with the legal
services authorities and other NGOs to
improve the quality of Legally today
constitutional mandate provides that
every man woman and child to be given
free legal aid at the state's explains
but what is the need of today is
effective legally thank you